they are advoc advocating for the
advancement of transgenderism he dives
into a bit more on how this is so
pervasive within our Health Care system
now uh he's going to reference something
called W path in the in the uh clip
we're about to show you it's the world
professional association for transgender
health and listen to how our health
system has been so warped around
gender unaffirmed
care improve long I can't say whether
there were whether there were peer
reviewed studies at the time um uh I I
believe that you know even today we
don't know the longterm consequences
necessarily of some of of those specific
drugs but certainly with with respect to
the transgender uh Pharmaceuticals there
are no long-term studies uh
peer-reviewed that show the advocacy uh
or or not um of of of taking these very
powerful Pharmaceuticals and um um you
know we we may not know for some time
and in fact what what has resulted in
this has resulted in a situation where
clinicians and institutions and
academics and elementary schools and the
entire gamut of this supply chain uh has
have to fall back on protocols
established by an organization called
wpath wpath stands for the world
Professional Association of transgender
health
it's technically a medical uh
professional body established in the
1970s um and um but I think what's
unique about it uh is that it's it is it
is for sure you know a a medical entity
uh but it is also an advocacy
organization and a political advocacy
organiz for sure so in so far as they
are advoc advocating for the advancement
of
transgenderism
so in other words uh the protocols and
clinical protocols that H Health Systems
um you know large and small that are
fall are falling back on are the
standards that
wpath um has enacted over the years all
right so he's making a really
interesting point there the whole system
itself the financial incentives and then
these activist organiz organizations the
system is designed to push more people
to transition what are the chances
really think about this you bring your
8-year-old daughter to one of these
clinics and your daughter says she's a
boy and you're trying to make some sense
out of it and somehow the whole the the
the education system the cultural
institutions they've all pushed you to
now go to this place do you think
there's any chance at this place they're
going to be like you know what no
actually your your 8-year-old's just a
little bit confused send them home you
know take them for a walk go on vacation
whatever it might be right like clean up
whatever is going on in your own house
have you confused them about gender
roles or or God knows what right like
whatever it might be is there any chance
they turn people around that would be a
great we should get in touch with this
guy that would be an incredible thing to
find out when people go to these gender
clinics with their kids how many people
are turned away or do they affirm what
anyone is thinking regardless of age and
brain development and everything else
right just because you're eight years
old and believe that you're a Sith Lord
it probably isn't true occasionally it
is you got it Anakin you know didn't
work out the way we all wanted but okay
he came around to the
end